what it sounds like when you're
describing these men and I'm actually
getting more and more sympathy the more
that we go through this interview they
just sound like blokes have fallen
through the correction Society right
yeah it's just disenfranchised young men
and uh unfortunately historically
disenfranchised sexless unpartnered
young men a surplus of that demographic
of people in a society is has
historically been very dangerous in The
evolutionary psychology literature we
call that young male syndrome and
they're typically the most prone to
Crime because they have elevated
risk-taking and Status striving
behaviors so I recently heard it
described as uh that they have like a
need for chaos that they'd rather just
tip the whole Monopoly board of society
over rather than participate in it
because they feel we don't have a stake
in this society and nothing gives a
young man a stake in society more so
than a partner so and and on that point
uh I first of all incredibly worrying
that China has a large number of men who
can't get married basically but also the
question I wanted to ask you is is it a
case of we've got more people in that
position than we've ever had or is it a
case where we now have technology that
allows people who otherwise would have
been sitting in their mother's basement
and playing computer games well now they
have a community we all now have a
community we're all part of some
community and we can go online and we
can talk to other people who are part of
that community and we become embedded
and I know one of the concerns
particularly with insults is the being
on an Intel Forum they don't want you to
get better right the moment you start
actually getting dates and you know
whatever you become very ostracized
right so is it a case that we've got
more people in this position or is it a
case that the tools of modern
communication have allowed people to get
together and be like we're all in cells
together right so yeah I touched on some
very very key points there so
historically uh throughout our
evolutionary history we always have had
a greater variability of male
reproductive success so a lot of men
throughout the Revolutionary history
haven't got to reproduce so we've always
had a an inside problem however we had
institutions to kind of deal with this
kind of surplus population you had
monasteries you had even unfortunately
and maybe an unpalatable idea is the
idea of war and sending young men off on
raids with the the promise that they
will be able to get a wife that way so
Mary Harrington who I understand you've
had on the show she wrote a really
interesting article on inselves as the
new Vikings so Vikings historically
would have been a prototypical himself
unpartnered young men who could be sent
raiding in war so those uh kind of
cultural institutions aren't really
available perhaps I think it's clear
that's a good thing but it does leave us
with this Surplus population I think
you're right that the online worlds have
given all sorts of communities a chance
to kind of galvanize around together and
that might make this particular group of
incels uh unique in history to be the
first to consciously grapple with the
fact that they they may be to some
extent an evolutionary dead end uh
directly which is you know might really
mess with someone's psyche there's also
uh the kind of modern features of the
modern mating Market that are
evolutionarily mismatched with our
ancestral mating Market that maybe
exacerbate problems there as well so if
you think about it in our ancestral
environment you would have encountered
perhaps a couple of dozen potential
mates in a lifetime so persistent sexual
rejection would have been perceived as
catastrophic you know if you if that got
a up and running you could potentially
oh I'm a dead end here
um whereas that's not quite the case now
but the rejection still hurts the same
and someone in the modern dating Market
with dating apps big cities transport
around could encounter more rejection in
one day that would be possible in a
lifetime in our ancestral environment so
for the psyche Still Remains the Same so
that that may compound any negative
effects on the well-being and a couple
of other evolutionary novel features of
the modern amazing Market are the online
way it's ubiquitous way to meet your
partner now I think 70 plus have people
since 2017 have met their partner online
and that means that the the competition
you're up against is everybody in the
wider vicinity not just who's in your
neighboring tribe it's just the whole
world is against you and the way that
works negatively is that for an incel a
woman of maybe similar what we would say
a similar mate value but she might be
able to to meet a guy of higher mate
value online and he will be willing to
to have a sexual experience with her
maybe once or twice but not commit to
long term but she gets the idea that's
my level and that's what I want now I'm
going to keep chasing that and perhaps
you'd say well why shouldn't she you
know but um it may also be an
uncomfortable truth and that we have to
wrestle with that for most of our recent
history women had been settling with
guys that they really weren't that Keen
on but just out of strict monogamy norms
and strict uh economic necessity they
kind of had to now that women are
beginning to outpace uh men in education
certainly and up until the age of 30
economically
they're kind of there's a mismatch of
Highly Educated and selective women
versus economically unattractive men
because the the female mate preference
for a similarly High earning or uh
higher earning partner Still Remains so
those minority of men at the top so
there is a sign of some truth to this
cliche of a minority of men are kind of
monopolizing the attention uh that's
born through in a lot of studies that we
see and in a lot of um kind of facts and
figures that illustrate that point there
is some truth to that and when you have
a minority in any sex ratio they're
called the shots in terms of uh sexual
behavior so if there is only a minority
of women in a a society the men are more
keen to commit long term whereas if you
have only a minority of eligible men
then they call the shots and they're not
they're reluctant to commit and the the
socio-sexuality of the other sex has to
mirror the whichever is in the minority
it's a fascinating way to look at like
something so fundamental as sex ratios
and uh there was even one really cool
study that these researchers called Rob
Brooks and Candace Blake they were able
to predict Geographic areas of high
online Intel activity based on three
variables number one high income
inequality overall number two small
gender pay gaps so women earning nearly
as much or more than men and number
three male biased sex ratios so fewer
single women so all of those together
could predict Geographic areas of intels
around the country that was amazing